[MUSIC PLAYING]
KALYAN REDDY: Hey, everyone.
Welcome to "Google Apps
Unscripted." My name is Kalyan
Reddy and this is my coworker,
Dan Lazin.
DAN LAZIN: Hey, everyone.
KALYAN REDDY: Sorry about the
technical difficulties.
We're having a lot this morning,
so you're not going
to see a Hangout link.
And obviously, we're running
several minutes behind.
So instead of the Hangout, just
go ahead and post all
your questions on the [? Dory ?]
and then we'll look
at that frequently as
we do the show.
DAN LAZIN: That's just the
moderator link at the bottom
of the live page at
developers.google.com/live.
Go to this event and there's a
moderator link at the bottom
of the page.
KALYAN REDDY: So again, sorry
for the technical
difficulties.
We do have a lot of content,
good content here today.
So I wanted to start out by
saying, if we have any new
viewers, basically what is this
"Apps Script Unscripted"
if you haven't seen the
last couple episodes.
If you're familiar, last year we
were doing something called
"Office Hours." "Office Hours"
are, basically, we come and we
talk about release notes and
answer some questions people
posted on the moderator.
This is basically the same
thing, just re-branded.
And we're doing it less
frequently so we can encourage
more live participation.
Unfortunately, today
we can't have that.
So we have a couple of these
different kinds of episodes
that we are producing.
So one is called this
"Unscripted," which is what
you're seeing today.
And then we also have a "Crash
Course," which is like a
deeper dive into
certain topics.
DAN LAZIN: That's right.
KALYAN REDDY: Arun Nagarajan,
our other teammate, he did a
bunch, one on ScriptDb
that was really good.
DAN LAZIN: Yeah, that
was really good.
KALYAN REDDY: And
content service.
And other than that, we also
have a new series called
"Scripted," which we showcase
interactions between Google
Apps Script and various other
Google properties.
You know, how to tie things
together really well.
So we recently did a "Scripted"
on YouTube, so that
should be really exciting.
DAN LAZIN: Really sucessful.
KALYAN REDDY: Go and
check that out.
Other than that, anything
else we have coming up?
DAN LAZIN: Let's tell people
about all the changes in Apps
Script in the last month.
KALYAN REDDY: Oh yes, we have
lots and lots of changes.
So if we can switch to
the computer here.
Awesome.
All right.
So I guess let's start with the
beginning of February here.
DAN LAZIN: So we're looking at
the release notes page on
developers.googl
e.com/apps-script right now.
KALYAN REDDY: Right, it's all
the way at the bottom of the
left side nav panel.
So in case you want to refer to
that in future, go ahead.
Go there.
So a feature that we added in
the February 11 release was
that you can attach StaticMap
objects directly to emails.
So it's kind of nice.
You don't have to convert it to
a BLOB and then attach it
as an advance parameter
or anything like that.
You just go ahead and, bam,
throw it in there.
One step method to
simplify things.
Let's see.
We had a couple of issues
that we fixed.
As you can see, the list
is pretty big.
Some key things that I
wanted to highlight.
We did have some issues with
the quota dashboard.
We fixed that.
DAN LAZIN: Now one thing.
A lot of people aren't
aware that the quota
dashboard even exists.
You want to pop it open and
show them the link?
KALYAN REDDY: Oh yeah,
that's a great idea.
So here, you can go
to Dashboard.
And this is a Service Health,
which tells people how our
services are doing at any given
day in the last week, in
case we have any problems.
And here's the Quota
Limit section,
where you can go and--
DAN LAZIN: The quota limits is
really good for looking up
whether a script that you're
building is likely to exceed
the allowable quota for
your account type.
Basically, that's dependent on
the sort of domain set up you
have, whether you're using
Google Apps for Business or
just a regular consumer account,
you get different
types of limits for different
sorts of Apps Script services.
KALYAN REDDY: Here, let me
give you a quick example.
So Email Recipients.
So this is how many different
recipients that you can send
an email to on a per day
setting, which is what this
quota is set to.
And if you're just a consumer
account, then you can send 500
recipients per day.
So that's either 500
sent emails or it's
500 cc's to 1 email.
However you want to
divvy that up.
But if you go to the Google
Apps for Business
side, you get 1,500.
Because there are use cases
within the domain setting
where you need to send more.
So we'll relax that.
And the same thing applies
to various
other services as well.
And they're scaled up
appropriately to
your account type.
So check that out.
And just a quick note.
We are working on some
improvements to the Service
Health dashboard.
Stay tuned for those.
Basically, we're trying to make
it so that it's a little
more responsive to--.
Basically, the thresholds will
more accurately reflect if
we're having some problems.
DAN LAZIN: That's a
really good idea.
KALYAN REDDY: Yeah, a few times
in the past, we've had
problems with like a method
or two here or there.
Overall, the service itself
was working, but these
problems didn't trigger
an update on the
Service Health dashboard.
So we want to fix that and we
want to get this information
out to our users as soon as
possible so then they can
notify their users and
then make sure
everything's working smoothly.
DAN LAZIN: Of course, if you're
running into a problem
that you think might be a bug
with Apps Script, always a
good idea to go to our
Issue Tracker.
Take a look at what
issues people have
been reporting lately.
And see if the issues you're
running into are similar to
these because we keep a very
close eye on that.
Kalyan is the master of the
Issue Tracker these days.
And we try to really keep
on top of the bugs.
KALYAN REDDY: Yeah, just take a
look at the new issues that
are still outstanding.
If your issue matches, add your
support information to
that thread.
If there is no existing report
of an issue, go ahead and
create a new one.
And then please put your
project key in there.
That really helps us look at the
server logs to see if the
errors that you've been getting,
if we're able to
catch any of those.
And then we can dig in and have
our engineering team work
and really investigate better.
So that's key.
Let's see.
Back to the release
notes here.
So one big thing is, you might
have noticed that your users
are having problems installing
your scripts
from the Script Gallery.
And this is if you had onInstall
functions in there.
So we looked at the issue,
and we provided a fix.
And that should be good
to go right now.
A couple of improvements
to Ui App.
So some of the widgets there
weren't 100% in parity with
their good counterparts.
So for example, PopupPanel,
we added the show and hide
methods so that you can
actually use it now.
So setFocus.
Let's see.
Added client handlers
for the ListBox.
That's good for this release.
You want to take this February
14 release here?
DAN LAZIN: Sure thing.
In the February 14 release of
Apps Script, we added an
openByUrl method to DocumentApp,
as you can see
right here.
You have noticed we've sort of
rolled that out to a variety
of our services over the
last couple of months.
It's just a convenience
factor.
You can always open them
by ID as well.
But now you don't have to snip
out the ID from the URL and
paste that into Script.NET.
Just grab the entire URL.
It's a lot easier, especially
if you have scripts that are
requiring other users to sort
of tell you what documents
they want to interact with.
End users sometimes don't
understand about grabbing just
the key out of the URL.
So now you can dump in the
entire URL as a string.
Very handy.
KALYAN REDDY: That's
a good point.
And what he was referring to is
that we also added this to
spreadsheet apps.
So you can have a user just put
in their entire URL and
then have it there.
You don't have to do any weird
regex behind the scenes to
extract after the key equals.
Whatever that thing is.
It's simpler.
DAN LAZIN: Yep, exactly.
And just a few small fixes
in this release.
The makeCopy method of the file
service doesn't give you
an error anymore when you're
creating a new Google form.
You might have noticed, a few
weeks ago in Google Apps we
rolled out a new revision of
our forms application.
Much more powerful now.
Much more configurable.
And we're just catching up to
make sure we're supporting the
same file type as them.
So you can interact with those
at a basic level now through
file there.
And a couple more changes
to error messages.
This last one here, which
was Issue 747.
It's actually a really
nice change.
What this says is, error
messages now specify in which
code file the error occurred.
So now when you're running a
script in the Script Editor
and you get this red bar across
the top that says, hey,
there was an error.
It used to just tell you what
line number it was.
But if you had multiple lines
of code, or if you had
multiple code files in
your project, it
wouldn't tell you--
it was line 50.
But you didn't know if it was
line 50 in your first file,
your second file, or
your third file.
Now it explicitly tells you
what file it's in as well.
Makes it much easier to go
through and look for errors.
KALYAN REDDY: That's
a huge change.
Especially for people who are
developing these massive
scripts now.
And reducing the complexity by
having different files to
organize your logic.
Now this makes it much,
much easier.
DAN LAZIN: And keep in mind
as well, that if you're--
for our sort of newer users,
if you're using, if you're
running into bugs, in addition
to just looking at the error
message popup, there is a
debugger function in the
script editor that not a lot
of new users know about.
Just a little bug icon.
It's like a debugger you'd find
in Visual Studio or CLIPS
or any sort of real IDE.
It allows you to set rate
points, walk through your
stuff, inspect your variables
as they're going.
It's really useful.
KALYAN REDDY: And actually,
maybe the next "Crash Course"
should be about the various
debugging techniques.
DAN LAZIN: But that's
a great idea.
There's a lot of
hidden secrets.
KALYAN REDDY: Because there
is the debugger.
There's other things you
can do, like if you're
investigating the doGet flow.
You can drive it by building
like a test function and
calling it with certain
parameters.
You can do that with any
function that expects
parameters, by the way.
So maybe we'll do another
episode later--
DAN LAZIN: That's
a great idea.
KALYAN REDDY: --where we show
the various methods.
DAN LAZIN: Yeah, there
are lots of little
secrets in Apps Script.
Like even just the keyboard
shortcuts to run a function to
open the logger.
KALYAN REDDY: Ah,
Control-Enter.
DAN LAZIN: Yeah.
There's a keyboard shortcut
to automatically
indent your code file.
And some of these things are
great hidden secrets.
So we should tell you about
those other things.
KALYAN REDDY: Exactly.
Let's see.
We've got to get to the
moderator pretty
soon, but let's see.
Is there anything we want
to highlight here?
Set colors up here.
DAN LAZIN: The February 25
release is mostly just
catching up with breakages.
KALYAN REDDY: Yeah, some
bug fixes there.
Some good stuff there.
So if you're interested in any
of these or these issues apply
to you, we try to update
each of our issue
logs with the fix.
And you don't necessarily get
the notification if you
weren't one of the people who
originated the issue or cc'd
and added your information
to the issue.
So go ahead and check
the release notes.
And then you'll find out
good information, like
what we just said.
Let's see.
Let's go to the moderator.
Jump to the moderator here
and see what we have.
Good.
We've got a couple of
questions here.
OK.
So it looks like we've got a
question here on ScriptApp.
"Any plan or hope on
getting ScriptApp
service fixed or updated?
So we can manage script
versions, library versions,
deploy as web app, setting who
can access, et cetera.
This is a must to deploy web
apps to other domains."
Good question.
Good point.
Off the top of my head, I don't
exactly know what the
current functionality, like the
complete functionality of
ScriptApp is.
I've been able to do a lot of
simple stuff with ScriptApp
programmatically.
But maybe it's not fitting
your needs.
And it's understandable.
If you're managing huge domains,
there's other use
cases that we might not have
anticipated previously.
So if you are running into a
wall anywhere, please check
the Issue Tracker.
See if an enhancement request
has already been posted.
And if it hasn't, bring it up.
And we do monitor that.
There is a big list there.
But it's because we want other
users to see those as
well and star them.
So if there isn't an issue
originated for this, please
originate it.
And if you're another user who
sees this issue, raise the
star count for it.
Because the more stars an issue
has, the more importance
that we present it to
the Eng team with.
Because we'd love to implement
every one of
these feature requests.
But the fact is, we
have bug fixes.
We have other features that
are higher priority.
It's just, we need to prioritize
things such that we
are using our time wisely.
And we're improving the product
in the greatest
amount, every iteration.
DAN LAZIN: Exactly.
And a reminder when you're
putting in a request for an
enhancement like this, it's best
to split up sort of into
individual parts.
We would love to do everything
we can to make ScriptApp meet
every use case possible, but if
we sort of chunk it up into
smaller requests.
In this question here, managing
script versions as
one ScriptApp function, managing
library versions as
another ScriptApp function.
Those may be different amounts
of work, and we can maybe
prioritize them separately.
So small, really achievable
requests are our preference.
KALYAN REDDY: And here's
one I was looking
at this just briefly.
"Hello, could you help me with
the Contacts API version 3
access to users across a domain
using Apps Script?
More details and sample code
in this topic." So I
looked at the topic.
And it's basically a posting
of trying to do two-legged
OAuth in order to query
the Contacts API.
I'm not that familiar with
directly querying the Contacts
API, but you should
be able to.
If you can do it with a web
browser, you should be able to
do it similarly with the
URL fetch and other
mechanisms as well.
I believe your problem might
be that you might not be
implementing the whole OAuth
dance process correctly.
One of my coworkers,
[INAUDIBLE], he actually
recently was able to come up
with a nice sample that shows
how to do this whole thing.
So I'll dig that up and I'll try
to get back to you on the
Stack Overflow post, I guess.
DAN LAZIN: Yeah, that's
a great idea.
KALYAN REDDY: Maybe
that'll help you.
Once you get the OAuth thing
working, then you should be
able to do everything
you can normally.
Let's see.
"We develop many intranet
sites with Google Sites.
Unfortunately, Apps Script
gadgets take a long time to
initially render when embedded
in a Google site.
The same gadget works much
faster outside of Sites.
Do you have any plans to speed
up the execution?"
So I guess this question is
saying that if you built a UI
in HTML service or UI app, if
you just expose it as a web
app, it's coming up much faster
than if you put it as a
gadget in the site.
DAN LAZIN: I haven't run into
that issue myself, but--
KALYAN REDDY: I haven't come
across this reported before.
So if you can actually quantify
this difference-- and
it's not just one random
instance on a day which varies
on server load, but it's
consistently happening--
post us a small sample on the
Issue Tracker of an example UI
that you're using.
And we'll definitely
test it out.
We'll test it as a web
app and as a site.
And if there is a bottleneck,
oftentimes there are things
you can do in code that makes
it render faster.
We can analyze the bottlenecks
as well and get back to you
with some feedback.
So go ahead and distill that
down into a small sample, and
then post it on the
Issue Tracker.
And then we'd love to help
you out on that.
DAN LAZIN: And if you're using
HTML service, there's a few
tricks you can use to, not even
necessarily get the app
to render faster, but appear
to be a little more
responsive.
If you make more dynamic
requests and there's rendering
sort of a small amount and then
fetching your data later,
users will at least see that
something's happening and give
them a spin or something rather
than just waiting for
the entire thing to load.
KALYAN REDDY: Exactly.
That's a great idea.
Unfortunately, I think we're
out of our scheduled time.
We apologize again for the
technical difficulties in
starting this.
Next "Apps Unscripted" will not
be quite as unscripted.
DAN LAZIN: That's why we
call it "Unscripted."
KALYAN REDDY: Yeah.
Yeah.
So tune into that.
And we might actually do the
"Crash Course" on debugger.
So look out for that.
If you follow any of us on +
or if you follow the Google
Developers channel, we're
going to post
reminders for this.
Put it on your calendar.
And we'd love to have you
at our next episode.
So thanks for joining in.
DAN LAZIN: Once again,
I'm Dan Lazin.
KALYAN REDDY: And I'm
Kalyan Reddy.
DAN LAZIN: This is
He knows his own name.
It's amazing, this guy.
KALYAN REDDY: All right, guys,
DAN LAZIN: Take care.
KALYAN REDDY: See
you next time.